Welcome back everyone this will be my deadpool
3 video marvel just made a bunch of big
announcements about the movie all good things so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos the deadpool and korg video was just the
tip of the iceberg them crossing him into the
mcu i will say careful for spoilers for doctor
strange too because we'll talk about some of the
deleted scenes during that and there's still a
couple people on my recent marvel videos that say
that they have not seen doctor strange two yet for
some reason the funny thing about deadpool
now with the kang multiverse war and the
secret wars the incursions lead up is that the
timelines are very confusing mcavoy or stuart
these timelines are so confusing but you may have
seen a bunch of marvel reports in your feeds about
deadpool 3 the past week the big news is that
marvel just finally hired a director officially
for that movie meaning that it is actually
moving forward like they were working on a
version of it before for the past couple of years
so marvel just hired sean levy to direct the film
most of you are familiar with at least some of
his movies he's done a lot of really big stuff
the big connection to ryan reynolds is that he's
actually directed the last two of ryan reynolds
biggest films he directed the free guy movie which
actually had a bunch of marvel easter eggs in it
evans cameo who actually freaked out about the
character using captain america's shield like
he was acknowledging that he had played a version
of captain america talk about fourth wall breaks
very in the tone of deadpool he's also one of the
directors and one of the producers like one of the
core creative people on the stranger things series
he directed that stranger thing season 4 episode
4 video with the kate bush song that everybody's
been going crazy about on the internet for the
past week so he's just a director who's known for
doing a lot of comedy in the tone of deadpool and
working a lot with ryan reynolds personally on
movies in the past so he's a pretty solid pick
when that happened another really big thing
happened they rehired the original writers
of the first two deadpool movies rhett reese and
paul wernick if you remember all the clips with
him talking about the movie the last couple of
years he talked about how they were working on it
even working on it in his house in the new york
area he'd been writing a version of deadpool 3
with these two writers i write it with two
other guys rhett reese and paul wernick who are
geniuses and amazing in you know in so many ways
and and we just have so much fun we actually write
it all right in here in this room um where i'm
sitting and um and we just have the best time
doing it together so we hope that we're gonna
there's a lot more to a lot more story to tell so
we hope we get to do that there's a couple jokes
that you told me about i won't say now because
i don't want to ruin it's in the third one but it
didn't make it to the second one but it was really
a really funny thing that was going on i was like
oh they'll never let you do that yeah you could
fill a gymnasium with some of the jokes that got
cut out of deadpool one and two that would get us
all arrested or turned into some sort of disney
liquid so when he's joking about getting thrown
in prison by fox because all the terrible stuff
they try to put in the first two deadpool movies
and now in deadpool 3 he was working on it with
rhett reese and paul wernick all those funny posts
that he made about him actually going to marvel
studios offices and meeting with kevin feige the
joke about him trying to audition for the role of
tony stark iron man and not getting it that was
for the version of the movie that they were riding
with those two riders a little while after that i
think because they were planning on bringing on
a completely different director they brought on
different writers from the bob's burgers movie
in the bob's burger series but it sounds like
what happened when sean levy actually was hired to
officially direct the movie he personally said no
bring these original writers back on bring ryan
reynolds guys back onto the movie and as part of
that those original writers were talking about
what was going on with the script and what the
movie was going to be like and what kevin feige
was having them do they did say that because
deadpool is coming from the fox marvel universe
he's meant to be like a legacy x-men character
as part of that big deal with them buying fox he
did say that there were a couple negotiations they
had to work out and talks about how they would
write the movie that would address that with him
coming to the mcu eventually the writer of doctor
strange too also said that he was going to have
a post-credit scene with deadpool at one point it
would have been like the funny second post credit
scene instead of that bruce campbell post credit
scene with him breaking the fourth wall kind of
like deadpool looking at his hand joking about the
evil dead movie series because those are also sam
raimi movies there have been a lot of jokes about
how they were going to bring deadpool into the
mcu how they would address it like wouldn't it
be funny if deadpool just showed up in the mcu
during deadpool 3 as if he'd been here the whole
time in the mcu is it going to have something to
do with the incursions the secret wars teaser
in the doctor strange 2 post credit scene
the writers were just saying that they actually
had to work all those details out before they
actually wrote deadpool 3. these are some of the
quotes that they've released about the different
way that marvel does things under kevin foggy than
fox did things with their deadpool movies because
originally there were things that fox would not
let them do because they were in the middle of a
buyout deal like there was a lot of stuff during
deadpool 2 that they had to get rid of and they
actually revealed this completely separate plot
for a totally different deadpool 3 movie that they
would have made had the deal not gone through and
marvel not gotten the deadpool character back they
said that when they were going to do deadpool 3
at fox and it was just going to be its own little
solo movie they were actually going to do a road
trip as a deadpool and wolverine crossover movie
that's right everybody wondering if they were ever
going to do a deadpool wolverine team up with hugh
jackman's wolverine it was actually going to
happen during that deadpool 3 movie and even
though the logan movie came out right around that
time and killed off the wolverine logan character
later in the timeline also the patrick stewart
professor x character from those original x-men
movies from that same line of continuity we just
saw patrick stewart totally come back in doctor
strange too even though he was playing a slightly
different variant of the character meant to be an
amalgam of all the versions of professor x we've
seen so far including from the x-men animated
series that's why they literally played the theme
song from x-men the animated series when they
introduced his character for the first time in the
illuminati's chamber and even though they killed
him off in the movie in crazy fashion patrick
stewart after the fact made some jokes about his
cameo and said that he would also love to come
back as a completely different variant of the
character again so if he's ready to do that after
the logan movie that also probably means that
eventually hugh jackman wolverine will be willing
to come back even though it'd be amazing if he was
the original wolverine when he did that during
a different part of his timeline bringing him
back as a variant is also a way to see him in a
more comic book looking costume now it's actually
easier for them to totally pay off that wolverine
deleted scene of the actual yellow costume
and there's so many questions about this all the
time even though it's the same response from the
marvel people kevin feige the people who wrote the
first two deadpool movies and are now back riding
deadpool 3 at marvel said that disney was going to
let them do raided our movie they weren't going to
mess with it or disney fight it or anything like
that marvel just got back the rights to daredevil
luke cage jessica jones punisher iron fist all the
marvel netflix defenders characters all that stuff
is basically like rated r content they created
this special section for disney plus with content
warnings on it for people with young children
just to prepare people for the idea that they
would eventually do rated r content in the form
of movies like deadpool 3. they confirmed that
the movie will be inside the mcu but it is kind
of meant to be its own thing what that probably
means is that you'll see a couple big crossovers
with marvel characters that make lots of jokes
about the mcu just in general they'll finally
address exactly how deadpool winds up in the mcu
it will probably have something to do with the
incursions but like you won't see a ton of core
avengers characters in the movie which i think is
fine like they won't bring old man captain america
or the ghost of robert downey jr's iron man into
the movie while he's busy someone but you get the
idea there's nothing that they're not allowed to
do for those of you asking when they're going to
release it in theaters they just had a bit of a
shake up and a reschedule with a couple movies in
marvel phase 4. right now the movie is on track
for 2023 release this is what the marvel phase
four schedule is that year first there's ant-man
in the wasp three quantum mania with the kang the
conquer in february that's supposed to come out
before loki season two which is also coming out
that year and that plot will connect with the
loki kang multiverse war the secret wars plot
the incursions then guardians of the galaxy 3 is
coming out in may that'll introduce adam warlock
the high evolutionary maybe a couple surprise
cosmic characters but it's largely self-contained
to this cosmic area the mcu everybody hoping for
silver surfer galactus some other like really
crazy fox marvel cosmic characters then captain
marvel 2 the marbles movie is coming out in july
that year another cosmic movie in a different part
of the universe so that means that now they have
an open slot for a november 2023 movie that's
probably gonna be when they release deadpool 3.
previously they had the fantastic four movie on
the schedule for that release date but because
john watts who was going to direct that movie he
directed all the spider-man movies for them just
did spider-man no way home left that so that he
could direct spider-man 4 eventually for sony and
marvel and also do this spin-off star wars disney
plus series that new fantastic four director will
probably want to write his own version of the
script with another new writer which will just
take like another six months meaning that deadpool
3 will be ready to release before the fantastic
four movie so the funny thing is that even though
this is rescheduling all but ties back to what was
happening during doctor strange too because we had
a version of reed richards with john krasinski's
character the fantastic four movie we also
almost had a deadpool post-credits scene bringing
everything back around to that joke in the first
deadpool movie that scene feels like it has so
much more meaning now based on what just happened
in doctor strange too i'll do more deadpool videos
when we see more easter eggs we get more teasers
for the movie what's gonna happen this week is we
have an overlap between obi-wan kenobi episodes ms
marvel episodes and then we have a couple trailers
releasing so what'll probably happen is wednesday
i'll release my obi-wan kenobi episode four video
in my black adam trailer video my ms marvel
episode 1 video might post thursday morning but
then after that things will go back to usual all
that stuff will post on wednesdays every single
week make sure you enable alerts for my channel so
you don't miss any of that that's just the start
of it we're going to be eating pretty good this
summer there's going to be a lot of marvel stuff
coming also post schedule updates on my twitter
links for all that stuff down in the description
below and in the comments everyone click here for
my brand new thor love and thunder trailer video
in the clip that they just released and click
here for my brand new black adam trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!